bobby fischer's five most amazing moves
like this video now and we can have a
look at the most amazing moments
occurred in this brilliant champions
games he was considered one of the best
players in the world do you agree or
maybe you will after these five moments
in this first example Bobby has the
white pieces against another very strong
player reshef ski and in this position
he plays an amazing idea can you find
the move drum roll please Bishop takes
f7 check mmm straighten your face which
f ski off the king taste can you see the
idea Knight to e6 here we go that night
dives into the guts of blacks position
and the black cream is now attacked the
problem here is black can't do anything
to save that Queen try as he might now
in the game which f ski decided to take
that night with this pawn
goodbye Queen Queen takes Queen and
Bobby went on to win the game if he goes
King takes Knight the King starts
running around the board and you don't
want to do that for your King no no no
no how can you checkmate it well queen
defy check would happen the King comes
to f5 g4 check opening up more lines
towards the black King the black King
has to take that pawn rook g1 check
another piece dives into the attack poor
ol black king e goodbye my friend for
example if the black King goes to h5 we
have the switcheroo Queen to g2 and the
Queen has a number of ways to dive in
with checkmate black can't stop all
these possibilities so it's game over a
very very quick victory let's now move
on to his second most amazing move the
second example has been called game of
the century and we will shortly see why
it's been named such a accolade in this
position Bobby is only 13 years old his
queen is attacked on b6 most mortals
would simply move that queen away but
not young Bobby can you see the move
Bishop to e6
fantastic switch round leaving his Queen
to be captured but now white is in all
sorts of problems for example if white
decides to take the night
we now go Queen takes bishop with a
lovely pin on that Queen and this is a
winning position if you play his Bishop
takes Bishop we can play Queen b5
there's no bishop in the way and white
gets checkmated King to e1 Queen - e -
boom - the King a big checkmate where
else can that King go when it can go to
g1 and now we see a technique that was
used in the game Knight to e2 this
Knight has the time of its life diving
in and out of the position King to f1
Knight to g4
hello King to g1 can you see the
beautiful finish to this fascinating
combination Queen to f1 into mning the
white king rook takes f1 and now the
nail in the coffin Knight to e2
checkmate brilliant stuff in the game
Donald Byrne obviously saw all his lines
he must be shocked by these 13 rows
fascinating brilliant and superb play he
decided to take the Queen this Knight is
the hero
he's on Broadway prancing around like a
Hollywood star and he deserves it
because after King G one look at this
Knight go what a wee little chap he is
Knight to e2 we call this technique the
windmill technique it Dancing's around
like a windmill King to f1 Knight takes
d4 check King to g1 Knight to e2 hello
King King to f1 Knight to c3 check hello
King King to g1 and now simply pawn
takes pawn the rook attacks the Queen
the Knight attacks the Brooke Bobby has
a fantastic position which he went on to
convert in some style brilliant stuff
from the young thirteen-year-old onto
the next case
the next example has some real poetry
surrounding it the White King is already
very exposed in the middle of the board
but we need to
bring in the cannonballs how do we do
that
always look for the most forcing moose
and in this position Queen takes f4 oh
there goes the explosion where can the
king go well first of all we can take
that Queen can't be young Bobby well if
you do take the Queen Bishop to h6 is
checkmate and this is the end of the
game the end of the road for white even
though black has so little material on
the board the White King is stuck in a
place it can't escape from a brilliant
combination in this position of the
Queen f4 white decided to resign because
the pieces are gonna flood in no matter
where the White King retreats to white I
had enough by this stage on to the next
example we now come to another shotgun
moment those moments where one move
pulling the trigger ends the game
immediately
Bobby has the white pieces his pieces
are dangerously hanging around the black
king but what move finishes the game
again have a go yourselves it is a big
move look for those very aggressive
moves like checks or captures Queen
takes h7 check and in this position
black resigned this move draws the black
King into the open for example King
takes h7 and now we continue the attack
pawn takes pawn double check something
we have seen earlier and the idea is
wherever the black King goes is
checkmate next move for example if it
tries to run back home the rook is now
open so it can come and give a bit of a
back ranker this is a terminology we use
in chess that is the back rank along the
back and that is a back spank checkmate
if the black King tries to come out into
the open can any other piece join in the
attack yes it can the bishop on g2
Bishop e4 checkmate
a beautiful combination now let's see my
last pick of his most amazing moves this
next position has a little bit more
Jonas a croire a bit more subtlety than
the other examples we've seen so far
is clearly attacking with his queen
lined up against the king he wants to
target the square on h7 so one obvious
idea is 'if I've but that is not the
move Bobby played Benko with his
opponent would have played f5 against
this a clever defense if I did trying to
exchange Queens off the board and at the
same time blocking this Bishop away from
its target so what is a better move than
a five can you see it rook to f6 a
beautiful move sacrificing a piece on an
empty square but at the same time with a
real purpose trying to stop the F pawn
from moving the idea is if Bishop takes
rook now we play e5 and the line is
clear - h7 next move the Queen will dive
into the square giving checkmates after
the roots wave sticks Benko is
completely helpless the game ended King
to g8 black can't do anything else
and now pawn to e5 the bishop is
released born to h6 and Bobby was in no
rush here
he simply played Knight to e2 black has
nothing he can do remember if he ever
takes the rook Queen takes h6 and the
Queen comes into the game brilliant
brilliant play and a fantastic it's at
one of my favorite examples there
remember like this video and leave your
comment below on which of those five was
your personal favorites idea and move
brilliant examples inspiring stuff from
one of the legends of the game Bobby
Fischer
happily oh look at these videos
[Music]